foi assim que eu perguntei
e aqui à margem do trabalho e de tudo
minha vida à água esteja sempre presente
uma cidade cinematográfica abaixo
as chamadas onde a cerca e em frente
a casa de um grande lago man
planos de inundação e que todos nós usamos
águas atingem a década desse tamanho e
mudar toda a minha vida a vida do meu
comunidade
eu queria saber o movimento
eu estava discutindo velejar eu disse mais
você é bem-vindo a oportunidade que nos liberta de
liberdade apresentada no final da tarde
o melhor de apenas o duro e
monumental eu me perguntava civil de
várias águas
para um sanduíche
porque os conterrâneos nos consertam de todos
canários na minha frente sendo capazes de ouvir
essas águas
enquanto as águas invadem
flores amarelas que maravilhosas
lugar de pensamento
vulcão para aqui neste lugar
eu sonhei
dez pessoas queriam acabar com isso
sentir nas calças
eu pensei por que
e às palavras que porque o sangue
idiomas das empresas no coração
do nosso importante no pantanal
é preciso mostrar sua importância
Nós vamos
federal de mato grosso destino de
possibilidades
Eu tenho que estudar a administração da bolsa
e pedreiros de trabalho porque naquele
momento em que eu tinha 23 anos eu queria
A floresta amazônica não sabe porque existe
uma maçã quando me dei maggio de
floresta escura misteriosa
etc
é ter um lugar aberto nacional
tem a primeira falha ecológica
estava descobrindo que estava feliz
economizando 40
Fui estudar o template deste
amanhã biquíni para tirar uma planta
aquático de poder novamente caminha abaixo
da semana as águas amazônicas e lá
porque se propõe a recomeçar oferece
a origem do caminho de contato um lugar o
milhares de águas quando o barco do pântano
garrafa como professor do
universidades
como pioneiro neste estudo e há
Comecei a pensar no número do compromisso
sonho curti pantanal
você saiu para procurar lugares cidade
onde você pode testar a importância de
pantanal de pessoas da calça para eua
a flor da califórnia e todos os
lugares foi felicidade sorte nenhum
interesse da calça
Eu virei a versão e continuo pensando e
negocia a rota dos ministérios
Eu também queria naquela época
sinto falta da minha família na sétima fila com
o parceiro queria em marfim
madeireiros comigo pensei no
desfiles de metrô também que a cidade
que defendeu o pântano no
numerando que mais espaço para o
Cidade
tem um que é filho paulo que me tem
citado para certas medidas é o primeiro
doutor de dl e novamente pioneiro
primeiro médico de ecologia maduro
começar tudo de novo abrir as portas
ele é para conseguir o sonho e
lá quando eu terminar
verdadeiro
começou a primeira expressão pantaneira
se eu não pudesse comer os amigos de
movimento e respostas onde era verdade
a empresa foi construída eu pensei
[Música]
um composto
tem uma integração de cooperação
Alemanha toda a estrutura foi colocada
base do pantanal publicamos uma melhor
livro que tem o canal
internacional com o mundo inteiro
trabalha no pantanal escrevendo o
livro
eu não sonho mais
é feito
ameaças continuaram mais de seis baixas
nas notícias do pântano
pântano coletando ar faz com que o
Chilenos, exceto os centrais
e um
mas eu estava perdendo entender como
fique saudável
e aí eu não sei
Nessa época comecei a descobrir
prefeito de fato um estudo
coincidiu no momento certo do samur
uso de inundação do projeto
impulsionado a ter uma ação melhor já
que após a energia da força para
continuar com saúde eu pensei que
eles suplantam para trabalhar a janela
trabalha com mais de uma rede de rios e
assim os mantém funcionando como um
corredor uma casa de 64
e quantos não especificaram a liga dos olhos vivos
os objetivos
e unidos ou molhados e fáceis acima de tudo
uma coisa é algo permeia tudo
margem de personalidade de uma coisa única em
tudo o que nasce da seita são
várias coisas
vários dos pequenos sistemas
trabalhando quando atinge a água sobe
esta inundação uma inclinação única
deixe ser o momento que eu não sabia por que
programação porque as águas do
alagamento do pantanal do pantanal de
peso do pássaro e da ração
as águas oferecem mansão florestal
amazônico
quando a idade de 102 anos ou menos teve que
ciência atualizada ok nós sabemos
isso e o pântano funciona como uma mensagem
de magia da totalidade de interação do
Água
e essa água beira elétrica dentro disso
pessoas de fora para escrever
amazona tudo me custa apenas forçado
interconectando
uma conectividade de água que são os
gente própria nossa
ancestrais também viveram primeiro
aquelas águas sofreram adaptação de sant
maneiras de envelhecer revivem essas
águas iguais e isso é ver como
fogo as águas do pântano novamente
inspirar pessoas com canais
a frase do famoso antigo que dizia o
sonhar um sonho são apenas sonhos
um sonho que está em uma rota na realidade
Eu pensei que muitas vidas na verdade
contribui com pessoas que são iguais
atingiu também um acerto ecológico de
quadris pantaneiros continuam por muito tempo
o tempo passa com o estar presente com
o que não é em termos de nossa
estrelas estarão passando para seus guardiões
será passado para o céu de 6 a 10
os seis pelos fios pelos mil
metros
Eu quero um bom relacionamento para ter
também essa presença é o pântano
já que não sabemos por que o pântano
pessoas mais velhas do mundo no momento
pântano
deste lugar como eram anos
por trás da frequência de drogas nada como
que aqui em várias histórias geológicas
histórias de cores pantaneiras que
eles começaram diferentes mais água modificar
mesma conta que todos juntos os
energia do que a desordem da água
descobrindo o exército nos estúdios
ele através da facilidade novamente yo
Eu pensei que era antes da oração
percurso também é o mais exigente
as pessoas estão nesse movimento
do fluxo das águas do pântano e como
sempre o barulho por trás de tudo
servidores também podem
mérito das águas do pântano
de todo o pântano para sempre
[Aplausos]